[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 49 out of
GameSpot after dark we are getting
really close to 50 we have nothing
exciting planned for the 50th episode at
least not that I know of but yet thank
you all so much for stopping by and
joining me this week is Lisa James hello
to more Hussien hi and so although
what's what's the background is that is
a viral video clip of let me actually
get the name of the video up but we use
it frequently because blessing myself
Lucy and a few others play overwatch
friendagenda podcast Simon Carly I'm
accordingly there various other folks
and whenever a blessing joins our our
party he plays that yes it's it's
actually an excerpt from the video
called
be a funnel it's being a funnel of
course that's what is called and it's
just like if the description is River
kids preaching and this is kid with a
mic and she's doing the whole
evangelical get hyped because God's
about speaking tongues it's 7 minutes
and 30 seconds long it is the most
clenching ly awkward thing you will ever
see it's this little girl just being
like speaking in tongues and it's just
this one bit where she says the phrase
is brushy Chievo about that's when the
blessings come in yeah yeah yeah there's
more I'm trying to find it other ones
cuz there's like great quotes in there
like yeah
and honestly like it's me like watching
this videos made my life ten times
better quarantine because it makes me
feel wanted it makes me feel loved
so there you go yeah the back story well
thank you blessing for joining us I
think you're the first guest to have
joined to have been on the show twice
now okay
that was my next question actually
because I was gonna I was gonna ask like
you know am I am I in the lead for you
in the lead but after dark yeah you're
probably the most probably like
requested as well really I don't know I
made the most immersive by the game spot
team now can I say I do have a complaint
there's the second column on the show
and Michael hi um isn't here where is
Michael hi um well we know good enough
II I mean you guys are great on this and
I just love Michael hi um you know the
other day so I stacks establishing the
show because my comment enough episodes
the other day I would know cuz except on
a piece I love you you were talking
about games stopped and said GameSpot
and you don't hear me giving you share
by it so yeah yeah so that's a
bold-faced lie because my DMS the other
day about the video what's up and I was
like where you're going to his jail
blessing well thank you for joining us
this week and it was pretty last-minute
I was like we should get blessing on
it's been a while and like I don't know
what four hours ago five hours ago I
message in you're like well I got
another podcast but I think we should
build make that work so they min for
sure yeah it feels it feels any other
podcasts that probably say no but game
GameSpot doctor dark almost 18 games
GameSpot after dark of course like I
gotta like I know like when you guys my
time because I joked that I look I
stopped listen to the podcast that's
maybe because I ran because I don't have
time in the day anymore cuz I'm a
podcaster now but if I was listening to
podcast as regularly as I was
oh you guys would be on top of the list
I it be after dark mhm
giant beasts cast and then bomb cast and
then all the other ones yeah in that
order
that's good one I will say I get where
you're coming from I use this in the
podcasts all the time until I started
working at GameSpot and now it's like I
listen to one a week if I'm lucky
well I mean also no one has a commute
anymore that's true that's another big
reason not commuting his yeah done that
too I listen to so many podcasts though
I'm just always I don't work if I'm
listening to someone talking let's do
music icon isn't dude not not when I'm
working like if I got up from to go from
here to go downstairs to get myself some
water I would put on a podcast like
that's the level of it's cuz i dont like
silence silence I need to like always
have some sort of sound going and I
don't like listen to music unless I'm if
I'm at home oh I'll listen to like a
podcast so I doesn't turn a lot
well anyway should we talk about what
we've been playing mm-hmm Lucy do you
wanna kick it off um I have been playing
ghost of sushi man I can't talk about
that until the embargo lifts next week
that's like not a humble brag that I've
been playing it's literally consuming my
life so that's what I've been playing
but also I downloaded The Sims 4 again
for a playful stream to do a goof Tom
and I are playing with Elise and James
Williams from funhouse earlier today and
that's that's James and Barbara Duncan
for you blessing oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
I love James and Barbara yeah it was
actually a Lisa's birthday at least of
course from roosterteeth her birthday
about a week ago July say yeah yeah yeah
yeah that took me a second that servant
the goof so he's playing yesterday to
set it up we did a challenge so things
that I've changed so differently from
when I played The Sims like I knew of
the exchange and I knew of ways to swap
custom content and people would post
stories and
lines and storybooks and stuff and then
with the sims 4 I didn't realize just
how much they lent into the community
created stuff and the fact that there
has this huge audience now online with
like so many Sims youtubers I need like
clash of on and a couple of other people
I'm like sim guru sim supply I didn't
realize that had this whole sort of
giant culture like I think everyone most
gamers have experience with the Sims but
I didn't realize just how strong it was
and how much it changed I guess and so
yesterday I was looking into what we
could do on the stream to make it a bit
more fun and not just hey let's just
make a seven phone run I found this big
list of challenges and so some of them
are like gold digger challenge what you
have to try and like marry and get as
rich as possible other these in-game
challenges are these oh no no sorry
in-game is in like you play them but the
rules are set up by the community ok I
see so there's obviously a hundred baby
challenge is very popular there's the
Black Widow challenge which I really
liked where you make a femme fatale sim
and then just get married and kill your
husband as much as possible and like do
that a bunch and so the the one that we
settled on yesterday was the three
little Sims challenge where you have
three separate Sims who all live on the
same lot three separate houses and the
rule is that you only control one sim
per day and the others have autonomy to
do everything they want to do so you
basically just like try and keep him on
track and see how they go off and do
their own thing and so today when we
were playing I downloaded the vampire
pack and the magic pack so I lost the
pets one so we had like one woman who's
obsessed with cats
we had a slacker teen called Liam who
eventually became a wizard and then we
heard a vampire called Rhys lemon you
know I really enjoyed who would who
would never walk anywhere he'd only turn
into a bat and walk and then reappear so
hilarious to see him like moved three
steps but disappear and read
those do that but then I mean the thing
that really got me about cuz I played
The Sims so much when I was younger just
like an impossible amount is the way
that they've changed builds and by mode
I mean like build mode and by mode of
one mode now and the fact that like you
don't have to the way that you can just
pick on a pre furnished room and just
drop it in is crazy to me it's like
incredible because I'm not great
interior design or anything I would be
the person who would spend hours and
hours in builded by mode but then the
way that it's so easy just to drop in
the pre-made stuff or even go on the
gallery and just download it and put it
straight in incredible and so I was only
supposed to spend you know half an hour
yesterday setting everything up and I
spent like two hours just planning the
Sims and then we played for a couple
hours again today and I have next week
off and so part of me is kind of
thinking well what could I do so I'm
excited about that it's kind of nice too
it's a kind of comfort game sort of
revisiting a lot of things about it that
are so familiar but it also has this
kind of sheen of being new because I
haven't played it properly in at least a
couple years I mean last time I put some
serious time into it was the cats and
dogs stuff that came out when I had a
household with me and Oscar Isaac um we
had a cat but that didn't save so it
wasn't on my PC when I booted up so our
IP that relationship but yeah zooms
Foreman cuz it was shite when it first
came out hmm I think that was the only
time I played it I think I played it
when i came out briefly and i was like
in version which was yeah the
constellation snps post a couple months
ago but the thing about sims 4 when it
came out and it's something like sim
based Sims games suffer from is that
you're coming off the heels of the
previous Sims game which has all the
expansion packs all the stuff packs
everything and then you have to start
fresh and you kind of have to put some
elements of that in the base game The
Sims 4 though didn't have it had very -
very weird omissions one of which was
swimming pools but the other which was
toddlers an entire life stay
which was so crucial before this is gone
and that was really weird and it just
felt very very limited and then they've
gradually patched all that stuff in and
had all these packs and everything and
yeah it's in a great place I love
listening to people talk about Sims 4
because at a certain point like
something will be said and I don't know
whether or not they're being serious or
not like whenever someone is like oh
yeah there was new DLC and and it
basically like expands out on the island
experience and you get to have an island
and have a tropical Fingal and I'm like
okay that sounds reasonable and then
like another person be like oh yeah also
there's cats and dogs y'all see and I'm
like if you wouldn't know the most
ridiculous DLC for Sims for laundry day
stuff that was voted on by the community
the community voted to put laundry day
stuff in there's like eco living I think
apartment life because I heard about
knitting recently being a thing and this
is that's the good life that's like
that's where the gaming industry as a
whole should be because we're here
people are here complaining about loss
of us twos ending needs to be changed
and certain characters need to have
different fates meanwhile Sims
communities that can we get a laundry
please as we get laundry so this yeah
actually I didn't realize that this it
even happened The Sims 4 nifty missing
stuff is the upcoming 17th stuff pack
for The Sims 4
it marks the introduction of knitting as
well as the return of the rocking chair
this is what this is the kind of stuff
that I live for so I'm very very into it
the return of the rocking chair it's got
a nice ring the game for a while these
are the boughs I can get behind
community stuff Park just developed as a
result of a series of votes for themes
built by and create same assets and
icons such titles similar to laundry
daily stuff rides the rocking chair
return of the rocking chair revenge of
the Rocketeer that's the only place my
brain is going right now when I worked
in retail we used to have like
cabinets behind the the cashier's desk
and they'd have like a bunch of games in
there the most popular we used to have
one entire Bay dedicated to Sims and
Sims expansions because they were there
were an absurd amount of them and they
were just selling all the time non-stop
it was like always seems like people
would come in and buy a game and then
just be like you know how you pick your
sides in a on a meal like should I get
fresh I get like mashed potato should I
get coleslaw people are like I'll take
that copy of the loss of us don't get us
in stuff pack on side please that's
awesome other games are like like
samurai shodown it's like oh yeah let's
collaborate with for honor for our deal
see get a new character making this huge
thing let's get the action going other
games are like yo let's let's not whole
level packs let's up the action and sims
is like you know [ __ ] it knitting okay
class on the show this is all like it's
had some incredible tie-ins over the
years they had not a Kea stuff pack they
had hmm you know Katy Perry had her own
pack like I'm like we're fun like can we
accidentally found like a maschino
hoodie yeah in our thing and then
carried on scoring is like guys a bobba
fett helmet hair and Darth Maul face
what's just no rhyme or reason to it I
think when the actual world is on fire
around you it's nice just to retreat
into the Sims cuz they probably own it
cuz it was free on PS Plus and Febrary
the PlayStation yeah cuz dave jury I
don't know from our UK team has been
streaming those on his personal account
and he's been doing a lot of Sim stuff
so I've been watching that and as I kiss
slowly been making me think maybe I
should install Sims and now I'm like
maybe I should install Sims
install the same setup tomorrow I
haven't got my new PC yet it's gonna
come at the end of July sadly but I do
have this gaming laptop and it's yeah
yeah yeah I could just like lay on my
bed with this gaming laptop warm in my
crotch I mean I would definitely put a
tray on or something cuz I mean this
like this gaming laptop even though just
running zoom
is already a mine that's the thing with
these gaming laptops us like we've
created the you know most up-to-date
graphics technology in a small form
factor but it's gonna scream like you're
beating at the entire time
jemelle through your desk tomorrow what
have you been up to slay this fire right
yeah I've also been playing ghost Ashima
I can't say anything about again good
title screen good couch great continue
screen sword in the ground text love
solid round well spaced left justified
text nice lighting back light good good
park effects more importantly when
you're lingering on the photo screen
doesn't make your fans kick into
overdrive like some games looking at you
Call of Duty war zone grow grow up just
by little get rid of get rid of that
infinitely walking forward group of
people just give me just text on a
screen that doesn't make my PS
fullscreen it's the only game I played
where I said this before where during
loading is actually for the PlayStation
have put a system level error that says
your ps4 is too hot
I've seen that once in my life and it's
playing that game and I was like I've
never seen that in any console ever
it was just like yo Co PS was too hot
I'm telling off turned off but I never
gotten that but I tried playing it about
a week ago and it was like okay you
gotta install a 90 gig update and I was
like alright you know just let it go
overnight it installs overnight and then
I go on to play with some friends and
it's like you can't play this you got it
download the game packs and then there's
like eight different packs I need to
install separately those no really the
multiplayer pack you can get rid of
single-player you can get rid of
specific I go over no special apps
because I was like yeah I should
probably do that but yeah then I just
had to install a bunch of other stuff
cuz I'm never gonna play this game yeah
it's weird out how crazy has gotten as
far as like all the different itemized
stuff that you I guess have to down a
little bit then don't have to have any
more and like the the fact that call
duty has gotten to the place where
they're like oh yeah hundreds of gigs
worth of data is
is needed to download to play this game
and I know I don't want to like be I
don't want to like be the person who's
like back in my day or whatever it's um
26 but like black ops on ps3 didn't have
that like why white why has it gotten to
such its lengths like why is it gone to
this point it's so it's us it's like all
the additional modes first so but then
this order in the batterer specifically
so they should have stuffing in there
for the future in it like it's a hidden
away and and like I think people have
said that it's not particularly well
optimized or as good as it probably
could be but I hope they figure that
stuff out especially when they
transition to the next generation and
inevitably have a new version of wars on
there if it's like a hundred and fifty
gigabytes absolutely not yeah I mean
wasn't this this cotton the modern
warfare engine was like designed for
next gen anyway yeah like they kind of
made it ahead of time so I wonder if
that is or why your ps4 is you know
about to catch on fire
yeah maybe so yeah cos the steam has got
a good title screen and I have been
playing Slater spire out for a bunch of
platforms for a while now and a lot of
people that I know talk about it like Rd
we mentioned before he's always been a
huge advocate of it and one of our own
Chris Pereira he loves that game and
he's always talked to pay and it came
out on mobile so I was that gal
commercial I think it was quite
expensive though yeah seems like a
tenner ten dollars or something like
that but I download it and I tried it
and I think I'm playing it wrong I so we
put out I think we should have a review
of it soon up Chris has written a review
and I read the review and as well as
reading the review I realized that I'm
playing entirely wrong like I was doing
the thing where I'm hoarding cards I'm
like oh every time it's like hey you can
have one of these cards which one do you
want I'm like yeah it's like you can
have this card you've won this battle
you can have this card can have the
money or you can get like a boost I'm
like obviously I'm gonna take the card
but the whole point of that game is to
kind of refine a smaller deck that you
can employ more frequently or that's one
of the strategies like you don't want
this deck of ninety cards with one
attack in it instead you want maybe a
couple of attack cards and a bunch of
cards that all like enhance those
attacks and give you more chance of
doing special abilities and that kind of
stuff
so I've been coming at all wrong but so
my kind of take on it is flawed from the
outset because of that I can see why it
was good but I didn't understand what
made it special I enjoyed playing the
card element of it but I was like I
don't get how this is better than any
other deck building game it has the
roguelike elements where you're kind of
working your way up up a tower and you
have to make decisions when should I
have this fight or should I try and go
around should I rest up or should I use
my experience points and you want to try
and make it to the end to fight the boss
should I fight this mini boss where
should I go around etc like that and I
was like yeah that's an angle but
doesn't seem that interesting but it
turns out I've been playing it in the
wrong way so I'm now getting into it
with a more clearer understanding of it
having read Chris's review and spoken to
Courtney a bit about it as well it is
fun I think the art style completely
puts me off its kind of low fire and
like dark dungeon II and but like it's
got very rudimentary animations and art
style like I want it I want to be I'm a
I'm spoiled for like interesting visual
aesthetics even in 3d kind of like card
games so I wish it looked a bit better
but ultimately the gameplay is there and
and it does have some a lot of depth to
it and I'm excited to dig into it but
yeah it's it's it's definitely something
worth claim I'm enjoying it for how easy
it is to pick up and put down so I'll
play in between sessions of like
Tsushima or like when I'm just like at
the end of the workday I'll just sit on
my bed and cry while playing still
inspire so it's like good for short
burst gaming so I do recommend it even
and British make sure you're playing it
properly not like an idiot like me
I said sleep inspires a game that I've
heard so much about but I don't have the
slightest clue of what that game is
other than its cards yeah it's very much
like it's pretty much you just you
you're just a little icon moving up this
path to the top of a tower where a big
boss waits and then each each little dot
is like a an encounter of an enemy and
then you just get a handful of cards you
play the cards and then you win you lose
you get an item back and then you move
on to the next thing and you're slowly
like making your way to the top so it's
very simple in it's much
anacs and all the depth is in the way
you build your deck and understand
there's like the other thing is that you
have characters who have specific roles
strengths and attributes and you unlock
them all the time i'm still playing with
the very vanilla kind of night style
class so i haven't got to the stage
where i'm not more interesting
characters but it's all in that how are
you making your build
does it work right now and how do you
build that out as you go ahead like you
don't automatically walk into each run
with a fully decked out build you kind
of make it as you go along so and and
then you can be like oh this time i'm
gonna try for a incredibly tanky build
so i'm gonna focus on minimizing my deck
so it's so it's focused on improving my
defend ability was also kind of like
having a small a variety of attack card
so i can tank through it or you could be
like i'm gonna focus on entirely
building around relics which give me
wild buffs and change the way the
gameplay works quite so you don't you
don't create a deck before you enter the
spire you create it kind of as you go
yeah so you come in with a basic hand
and then you kind of yeah so you're not
spending ages and menus kind of moving
things around odds and that kind of
stuff you kind of look at what you
caught and like dispose of things that
you don't want and keep add things that
you do one on the fly it's easily the
most approachable deck building slash
dungeon crawling slash roguelike game
and so on in that regards that's why i'd
recommend it cool I might have to give
that a try it sounds like like drafting
in magic together I don't know if
anyone's done that yeah it was like it's
kind of like a roguelike I guess in that
you make a deck on the fly and then you
use that deck for the next couple duels
or battle duels yeah yeah I dabble in
Walmart yeah I did some of the magical
growing stuff as well back in and it
does have that fight boy you're just
trying to make the most of what you got
and see how how you can take this limit
set of cards and use them in interesting
ways to get beyond of your enemies I
want to use your robe white that's what
I want that would be interesting just
because I hear people talk about Slate
aspire and for me I really like rogue
lights
specifically
games like dead cells and rogue legacy
have really spoken to me in a very heavy
way we're all getting very into those
games but like for the most part car
games still haven't necessarily done it
for me
well like specifically carved video
games haven't necessarily done it for me
yukio though is like the one exception
where I can get into a yugioh game and
so I'm sure there's somebody out there
did you ever play the ones for Game Boy
Advance which one like the tournament
ones or God I don't remember but I had a
lot of them and I played a lot of them
so like I so I the UE games I've played
right there is yu-gi-oh duelist of the
Roses for that was placed a yes - yes -
and I was like more so like a strategy
kind of game love that game I'm
specifically the soundtrack that still
has all my favourite soundtracks in the
game you go I do list of the Roses I had
you know dark duel stories for Game Boy
Color that I played a lot that was
basically this bastardized version of
Yuya where the rules were not anywhere
near what the actual rules were but it's
like a simplified easier version of it
got really into that and then on Gameboy
fans I did have I came up with the exact
name of it but it was like yugioh
dueling tournament 2006 or something
like that that were like these are the
you Year rules like these are the
official this is the official way to
play the game and you would work your
way up a few ranks with that and had a
blast that game that game got very
difficult because you Gil can turn into
a pretty hard game if you're playing it
casually but yeah you your rogue light
where it is like quick bursts of
yu-gi-oh sounds like a fun time there's
also a game yugi'll dual links that was
on mobile probably it probably still is
on mobile that kind of was an expedited
version of you go where it is smaller
Dex smaller hands smaller like feel and
all the stuff and sports so like meant
to be a mobile version of you you that
kind of fits within not necessarily a
roguelike but within like a condensed
experience of you do I want that plus a
rogue light make it happen the money
might happen I know that I've know there
I know there are developers I listen to
this make it happen please just for me
speaking of which do you want to go off
with the way you can play bless sure so
I got I got the opportunity to preview
hyper scape
which I'll know if you guys have talked
about hyper escape on the show or not
yet Michael talked about it last week a
little bit gave you gave me mouthwash
shoutouts obviously because I played
with Michael and so yeah like you saw
confide has invited us over to play
hyper escape which is their new battery
I'll game that I think just got out of
close beta and is set to release during
this summer at some point and it's
basically yeah like 99 players teams of
three takes place in the hyper scape
which is basically this future version
of the internet that is developed by a
company called Prisma dimensions it's
like there's like a lot of buzz terms
going on in this game but yeah Prisma
dimensions develop the Hybris cape which
is this version of the internet that
exists I guess like 50 years from now
that we essentially Jack ourselves into
and become one with the digital digital
landscape so it's like future Alma's
Internet yes yes I believe so I haven't
seen feature Amida long in a hot second
but I think I remember that episode yeah
something like that and yeah yeah you're
basically in it and so in that in the
hyper scape they have what they call
crown rush which is like the name of the
actual battle rate I was kind of like
basically like what they what what apex
legends is - apex legends crown rush is
- the hyper scape and so yeah like
people do for fun it's 99 players all
this different stuff the thing that
really I think makes this game
interesting for me is how much faster it
is than any other battle royale game
I've played it's like the bigger ones
yeah yeah like it is what if it feels
like way more of an arena experience
than any of the other ones
so like I would compare it more so to
Unreal Tournament or games like that is
law breakers were actually probably the
biggest comparison I would make in like
not in a bad way cos like I think
whoppers have pros why did you break
it's no more like like invoking God and
religion to save lawbreakers so the
second
I'll be all right that thing was in hell
uncle but like I so lawbreakers like
wasn't like a bad game by any means it's
just the game it just was a game that
kind of didn't take off to me hyper
escape has a lot of lawbreakers the
elements in terms of the movement and
kind of how quick it is and kind of like
this the art style a bit it feels like
it takes a lot H inspiration from that
but for a battle royale which I think
makes it more interesting because yeah
super fast-paced is super vertical and
so the game takes place the map is
basically a inspired by Paris like it
takes place in like an urban environment
and so you'll find yourself on top of
buildings and all this different stuff
because there's jump pads and there are
different abilities you can pick up like
there's a teleport ability that allow
you to teleport upwards if she wants you
or get to wherever you need to go pretty
quickly there are and they call these
abilities hacks which are there there
are things that you find on the map and
so yeah like you're collecting hacks
you're collecting different guns and it
just feels like way more of a of an
unreal tournament Battle Royale which
has me kind of excited but at the same
time kind of nervous because when I
played it I remember it taking a bit for
me to kind of like figure out the flow
of it and once I got there I was like
okay cool this feels chaotic like it's
it's fun and there is like fun strategy
to it and there is an accessibility to
it where you're just like like it's not
pub G it's not Apex where you're having
to find attachments for a gun and
different things like that it is hey I
have I got the Gatling gun if I want to
upgrade my Gatling gun I find another
Gatling gun on the map and that'll
automatically upgrade it and I can do
that four times it's like very it's
simple and clean it's easy
the thing is though like at certain
points especially toward the end of the
matches there we have the crown that'll
spawn on the map and what that is is
basically an any other any other battle
royale it's Last Man Standing
last team with with all their players
alive is the team that wins it's the
same here but with the added crown
element which I don't know how I don't
know how many players have to be left
for the crown to spawn but once the
crown spawns
whatever team is able to hold the crown
for forty-five seconds
winds and so it's a it's a it's a cool
thing there's no there's not a circle in
the game which is why I think they they
have the crown instead of the circle
what they have is the different areas of
the map disintegrate and it will
essentially like if you're if you're
left in an area of the map that is
degrading and disintegrating you'll
basically fall off the map that's how
they deal with pushing players together
in this huge environment the crown kind
of feels like the last effort of that
okay yeah once we once we have people
down to like one or two districts will
then have it what will then have it be
so that like the crown is what's pulling
people together the crown is gonna be
the thing that everybody can see if you
get the crown everybody sees where
you're at it is now a chase for
everybody just to get to you and so it's
fun in the sense that that is like a
strategic thing that is the thing yet to
kind of think about as a player of like
okay cool do I want to grab a crown real
quick or do I want to like camp on the
crown and like wait for its money to get
it so I can try and snipe them or kill
them or whatever and that's fun the way
kind of panned out for me when I was
playing this is like with Michael and I
think Khalif who were also playing with
when it got down to that it just turned
into a mess of bullets of just gunfire
happening everywhere me tapping whatever
button I can find like what doing
whatever ability that I have on me to
like try and stay alive and try and like
get people off me it turned into a big
mess which on one hand was kind of fun
on the other hand if every if every
match kind of boils down to that I can
see that becoming a little bit
problematic but I think that stuff might
be fixed with balancing guns and making
basically like balancing like balancing
different abilities and all that stuff
because the Gatling gun when I played
was like the thing that was super
overpowered and you know when when the
Gatling gun is the thing that is super
overpowered I think that's the thing
like that's what the matches are gonna
boil down to is that Gatling gun which
causes a mess so you know I I'm I'm
hopeful for the game i I think it's
pretty fun it's not like my favorite
battle right now is apex legends and
that's my favorite battle royale ever at
this point I don't think it's an apex
killer I don't think it's a fortnight
killer but I do think that it'll
probably have its place in the battery
all ecosystem which i think is pretty
exciting
do you think people who are kind of like
I don't know burnt out on the battle
royale scene are gonna be into this game
at all or do you think that it's not
really I think there's something there
because it's if feels different like I I
think when it comes to other battery
owl's especially the big ones so like
fortnight and pub G and even throw apex
into this I think the thing that can
maybe get tiresome of them is you'll go
rounds without action and then die
immediately and if you feel like you
wasted your time at a certain point
especially like if you go through all
the effort of looting and finding the
best attachment and finding all the
purple the purple pickups and all this
different stuff like if you if you if
you get your ideal loadout or if you if
you go down that route and then you die
let's say ten minutes in you know that
could be like that could be deflating
and you can be like okay well there's a
mood I that I have to be in order to
play this for Hyper escape it feels very
much like like it matches just way
quicker in the sense that you'll
probably find action and if you die
it'll probably be pretty quick and you
can get back into a match pretty quickly
and also like that's another big thing
is the revival system in this game
encourages getting people back into a
match like getting people back into the
same match more so than others even apex
like apex is the game that introduced
the whole respawn beacon and you get
people back into the same match this
game has it so that basically if if I
die as a player and I still have
teammates in the game I turned into an
echo and I'm able to still run around
the map in scout for my teammates I
can't shoot a gun I can only think other
players can see me like I'm just like an
invisible ghost essentially but I can
scout and you know help out my teammates
in that way and then for any other
player who dies there the place where
that where they get taken out then
becomes a respawn point to where now me
as the ghost I can go to that respawn
point and then my teammate who's alive
can meet me at the respawn point and
then bring me back to life
and so they're just like a lot more
situations where you're gonna get
respond in this game like I remember
playing a match with
Khalif and Michael and I got them back
probably like three or four times each
like back into the same game there's no
restriction yeah
and so like basically you're going until
your whole team dies and it's really
it's really active because of that and I
think there's I think there's something
there in terms of people keeping keeping
people involved in keeping people
interested so I could see people getting
into it for that that sounds neat like I
I'll probably try it I don't know how
into I'll gigs I've gotten super into
battle Royales last one I got really
into his apex but I I'm surprised that
Ubisoft and they said they were in a
battle I think I just kind of assumed it
would be like a Ghost Recon battle
royale because that world you have
already built for that and like it would
just make sense to like in in my head at
least it made sense like yeah Ghost
Recon like they can use that giant map
they can have a lot of characters on
that there's already vehicle combat
there's all this kind of stuff that's
already in place so like as much as that
still kind of interesting I'm glad that
they didn't just kind of turn ghost
recon more into something it wasn't just
kind of built to what the masses are
into right now docked me that they
didn't do Tom Clancy's blank-blank as
the battle because I feel like that then
has the name and they'll probably like
so a lot yeah maybe that they just had
the rights to do wild lands and whatever
and they haven't renegotiated with the
Tom conscious day I think they own it
now they can do it over there because
well there's Tom Clancy's the division
Tom Clancy's Rainbow six siege
Tommy's division was tumblr so more like
half at least half of Ubisoft games have
to be done Clancy at this point yeah Tom
Clancy's steep Tom Clancy's for honor
yeah yeah I also played a Iron Man VR oh
yeah I oh no I didn't find I haven't
made it that far so I've only made it to
chapter 2 and I think I'm done to get
him I'm not enjoying it that much it
it seems very fine like I don't think
it's bad by any means
it's one of those ones where I like if
we're if we're looking at it like for
the story and for the characters and lot
of stuff I keep comparing it to MCU and
I feel like this Iron Man kind of pales
in comparison in terms of like you can't
compete with Robert Downey jr. as Iron
Man and so like whatever whatever Tony
Stark talks in the game I'm like alright
cool I see where this is going I see
your humor I see your quips but you're
not Robert Downey jr. uh him you're not
him you know there's no bad the real one
you're not my dad but yeah like that
that's one complaint I have with it I
also feel like the controls are kind of
complicated in a way that I'm maybe if I
played it way more I could get
accustomed to you but the way that it's
set up right like you'll have you
playing with like two PlayStation Move
wands in so if you want to like if you
want to levitate or not levitate I guess
like fly or whatever do the Iron Man
like jetpack at the hands things you
know like hover yes thank you if you
want to hover right you like you'll
press down or you'll point down with
your palms and like click the triggers
not all them like boost you up or
whatever you can like go forward by
pointing back with your palms and doing
the same thing or you can shoot by like
palming upwards toward an enemy and then
pressing the center button on the move
controller but then you can use your
wrist rocket so I like playing down on
your palm it's like it's stuff that is
cool because it wants to make you feel
like you're Iron Man but for me as
somebody who like playing video games
and it's like so used to using the
PlayStation controller I'm like okay
cool this would be a lot easier if I
could just press triangle to do the
wrist rockets and press square to do
this thing I feel like I'm learning a
whole new way to play which one-hand
cool on the other hand kind of made me
frustrated and then yeah overall it just
kind of was a little bit bland for me
like in terms of the presentation and
all the stuff in the gameplay and like
the enemies are kind of all kind of
droney kinda enemies oh yeah again I'm
only I only just made it to chapter 2
you though and so like maybe down the
line like once things get flowing I know
Greg really liked it and shadow Greg
because he has a cameo in the game
chapter 3 which I wanted to get to you
but I don't think I will
yeah overall I think it's it's like fine
it's fine yeah
I can't play I get motion sick very
easily and I just don't even want to try
it and this does seem like a motion sick
kind of game yeah Rob and in our office
was saying that he was getting pretty
motion sick with it and I was like yeah
I'm just gonna I don't get motion sick
really but I watched the gameplay he
posted and I was like yeah I don't think
I could handle this I don't think my
stomach could handle that game yeah I I
can't I had I just about made it through
Batman and I love that game in VR and
even then I was like I'm sick oh this I
think the game that I can only rely BR
game I can only reliably play without
feeling sick is Tetris so oh yeah I can
only do the only stuff that doesn't make
me motion sick is five hmm I'll give us
music psvr makes me sick this quest not
yet like this quest has probably been my
best instance yeah we are in terms of
like it working
so I would say give that a shot possible
yeah cuz Greg's got a yeah index so I
might I mean I've got a week off I've
got space in here I might set up and
play through Alex finally yes you should
oh yeah we'll talk about that editor I
play it so have you guys heard of deep
rock galactic at all
the name rings a bell yeah name space
junking game right spaceship junko game
no it's not so I forget what that game
is called suit so this one is it I guess
the best way to describe it is kind of
like a left4dead payday sort of style
game but you're dwarves in space
basically it's a four player co-op game
you pick your class as you play through
these areas you get experience and
resources and you can level up your
dwarves but basically like the point of
the game is that you and friends go out
on these randomized mining missions that
are very much set up like left for dead
and that there's maybe not so much
different types of enemies that will
like pin you down or whatever but there
are a lot of different like randomized
scenarios as you dig through these the
these caves
and whatnot to find resources and then
bring it back it's super chaotic it's a
lot of fun especially you have friends
it's just like a very mindless sort of
not really a looter shooter but kind of
like a resource gathering shooter it's
it's on PC and Xbox it's it's really
good I am surprised not many people are
talking about it was an early access for
a while and I think it came out finally
in May maybe it was out like it heard
about it but I don't even remember the
context in which I heard about it it
sounds fun yeah it's really good like
they're they're kind of a lot of systems
in it like when you go to your main base
or whatever your spaceport there's like
I don't know a million different things
you can interact with like yours
you can customize your gun you can
customize your character here's a shop
here's here's a here's a bar where you
can go and get buffs for your next
mission kind of like Monster Hunter in
that sense there any cats making you
down before you go
no but there's a robot that serves you
beer and there's like a really fun game
where you kick barrels into this trash
can it's hard to describe but yeah I'm
super surprised how much fun this game
is I was playing with Tim Terry and
Michael Hardy and we were having a lot
of fun with it
did you say was in game pause I don't
think it's in game pass but it's on Xbox
it's only on xbox and pc it's cross play
between okay if you've got it on Windows
window or Microsoft if you get it from
the Microsoft Store you can play with
people on Xbox if you get it on Steam
you can only play with people on Steam
right so it's like kind of cross play
kind of not cross play but yeah I mean I
highly recommend it I think it was on
sale during the steam summer sale which
is when I first picked it up and then I
ended up getting it again on the
Microsoft Store so I could play with Tim
because he was on xbox but like I I've
been having a great time with it like
it's just you know mindless fun but yeah
other than that I've been playing six
six
which i've found is a very good game to
play right now because it's hard to
focus on anything else when you're
playing so six cuz it's just like you're
always thinking turns ahead you're
managing your units and your cities and
whatnot
but I was also playing that with Mike we
tried multiplayer for the first time and
like I don't know it's it's a lot of fun
I forgot how good that game was because
I played it when it first came out for a
couple hours and I was like I really
like this game but the games take eight
hours each and I don't have time to play
more but I haven't having fun with that
came to I am surprised at how into it I
am just because I think it's just
because they I've got more time right
now then I do otherwise so it's just
like I feel like I just put my all into
it and try to figure that game out it's
complicated as hell though as someone
who's never been that into the Civ games
trying to figure out like the difference
between like a religious win or a
cultural win or a military win it is a
lot but yeah I've never really been into
Civ but people say a lot of good things
about six and five and I'm like I just
don't think I can put myself I just I
don't think I'd have the patience for it
that's the thing I'm one of those people
that if I don't succeed
early on I will drop off yeah and
that'll definitely happen like the sip
sticks does a good job of acclimating
new players I will say that like like
when I assume six was the first one I
played and I feel like every step of the
way I was getting tutorial and not like
the kind of tutorials that was getting
annoying but it was like useful
information that I can opt out if I want
to but it was never too overwhelming
like it pretty much only gave you the
tutorials when you when it thought you'd
need them so wasn't it upfront telling
you all this stuff which helped a lot
but like as I'm playing through now in
multiplayer where there's no tutorials I
only have Mike trying to explain things
me and he's not the best all the time
Wow like he's all listening he's not
though ello he was if he came back to
the fold he's everyone's just like
ragging I'm Mike he's been he's been
helpful it he's been helpful there's
just been some things or he'll try to
explain it I'm like
and I'm just gonna I'm just gonna wing
it and see what happens but yeah I I've
been having fun with that I'm excited to
play more civics and then like everyone
else telling Gosa Shima but we can't
talk about that anyone else green the
sword it's okay war zone I knew I knew
what I do want to I do want to suggest
the game spot feature games yeah
GameSpot feature
Wow you know I don't think about it
because now I realize say every time I
say I'm like did I [ __ ] it up watching
watching Wayne I've got your message
conversation ready feel free to steal it
since I'm saying that's on a GameSpot
product you know this is all yours top
20 title screens billions well I think I
think we might already done that oh
really because I really want to see that
because I want to disagree I want to
fight um number one super metroid super
measure it's got a good one it's it's
it's too good man it's the go we haven't
done that yet but I know we definitely
talked about doing that as a feature I
think we talked about it at one point
yeah most effective most effectiv is
good with the little computer and you go
through yeah you mean he's good future
blessing okay won't take it will take is
the 64 count like with the face
stretching that's a loading screen isn't
it no that's the screen yeah you get a
pistol oh yeah you got I guess that
counts yeah that's a good one cuz I
spent too much time there yeah just
stretching his face pulling his nose me
hmm
anyway moving on to the topic for this
week best games of 2020 so far I I feel
like we're late to do this because it's
already July and I feel like most people
want to do it
June halfway through the year but I
don't know I stopped July we're fine
we've let that we've let the first half
of the year completely finish yeah yeah
that's a good point
I I think it's worth doing because we
did it last year I believe and I feel
like there's a lot of good games that
have come out this year
that need to be talked about i guess
maybe not need to be talked about but
should be talked about I mean I figured
we can just kind of open the floor
people can shout out games that they
think are deserving so far of some of
the best games of 2020 and we can talk
about it from there I know if there's
any vic jump to your head i've got one
that i want to talk about but i can wait
on that go on oh it's more half lifeless
i was gonna say a half my valleys half
live alexander this is by far my
favorite game of this year but it's
interesting because I don't think it'll
get that many awards because I don't
think many people have played it I like
tweeted the other day I was like hey
what are some of the best games so far
and not a single person said half-life
Alex and I had like quotes we did and I
was like no once in half-life Alex
that's kind of a bummer and a lot of
people were not mad at me but like
telling me that how hard that game is to
play which I agree with like I don't
think that game's gonna get a lot of
attention you know six months from now
because of how difficult it is to play
but man it's such a shame because that
game is brilliant like people are like
Last of Us two was a fantastic game I
really liked it but I think I think when
I like half-life Alex does so much more
to push storytelling forward in video
games and just the way that game is told
the way the characters are presented the
way you interact with the world that is
just missing and in a game in a naughty
dog style game which normally is at the
forefront of storytelling so it's
disappointing that that game is gonna be
very difficult for people to play like I
imagine it'll go down as a classic like
once the price of VR gets cheaper and
the barrier to entry is easier to get in
III imagine that would be a game that
people will like the other half-life
games that will people will constantly
look at as being like one of the
greatest but right now it's in this
really weird position where the people
have played it no it's good but like no
one's really played it and not because
they didn't hear about it but because
they just simply can't yeah and also
it's weird that it's like the best games
of 2020 so far to me it doesn't even
feel like half-life Alex came out this
year because my concept of time warranty
yeah like right at the beginning of it
yeah and like yeah I do want to play it
I'm not really a big half-life person
but I've had a lot of really good things
about Alex and do you want to play it
neither am i to be fair like I hadn't
played much half life until half-life
Alex in fact I started half-life Alex
and stopped because it was so good and I
was like I've got a playthrough oh yeah
so I went through played through all of
the originals which I didn't think at
age particularly well I thought they
were good but I wasn't obsessed with
them and I understand that part of that
is just because I missed out on that
time like it that technical presentation
kind of just missed for me because you
know I'm playing it 20 years after but I
think it says a lot that I was like a
couple hours and Alex and I was like I
gotta stop I don't want to know what
happens in this game until I know what
happened beforehand yeah my I mean my
favorite game of 2020 so far it's weird
because as much as I loved playing Final
Fantasy 7 remake I thought that combo
system was incredible I don't think I've
had an experience like The Last of Us
part two in a game probably since the
first maybe I type of I like to say
since the first last us I certainly had
a lot of experiences and games that have
been very profoundly affecting but I
think last was part two didn't expect to
love a B as much as I did I really
enjoyed that combat loop I think it
dragged towards the end but ultimately I
really really loved that game and I
would just I think one pro of quarantine
is the games like Last of Us where you
can't really dip in and out it kind of
demands a bit more of your time it's a
bit more involved I think that was the
thing that people had with Red Dead -
it's a game that really excels when you
play it in a long stretch and so last of
us I would be able to put in you know
like four hour stints on the regular
because I didn't have a community
anymore I'd be home already I could eat
dinner pretty early and then just play
through until I felt tired and
so I really enjoyed it I think the
acting in it is phenomenal range or the
writing i reaiiy really particularly
enjoyed that game hey loop and like i
bounced from because horizon was on sale
and i and i i think i towards my last
time I was on the podcast a few weeks
ago it's like playing my songs too much
but it's like it's really the difference
between the two where a toy is just
unbearable to listen to and that's not
Ashley Burgess fault but it's the fact
that she over explains every single
thing that she's doing then you go to a
Last of Us game where they it's still a
third person and a lot of the time your
character is alone but it trusts you not
to go not to have the character say oh I
should probably look for an exit oh no
there's wolves I should probably avoid
them you know like it's is maybe just
two different schools of game design
right and I guess you know the
difference there's that last of us is
very much more it's got more open areas
but very lynnium whereas horizon is you
know that big open world so maybe it's
just that but yeah I really really love
the Last of Us and so a miserable
experience a very emotional experience
but I think there were moments of levity
in there I think the hey I'm not gonna
I'm not everyone is a very beautiful
mission that makes everyone tear up yeah
oh yeah I the way I kind of it now which
is like no oh can you please send me the
fan art the way I kind of look at the
last part doing the way I kind of
explained it is because I know like
during the pre-release period I know
there's so many people that are like hey
everything's are you depressed in the
real world do I want to step into this
game that's gonna be this depressing
experience and I think the game does a
really good job of having like some of
the most dark and grim like most grim
moments I've experienced in a video game
but also someone most warm and like you
know personal and inhuman moments you
know like their moments in that game
where
you see interactions with Joe Llanelli
and these are no spoilers but like
there's some interaction with Joel and
Ellie that like war in my heart there
like some interactions between even like
Dina and Ellie or like but quite a few
different characters that like can we go
like man this game is this game is doing
a phenomenal a phenomenal job of
displaying humanity and like you know
there there's the whole quote toward the
release of this game right I think it
might have been like a year or so ago
where I think no Druckman was talking
about this game and explaining it as
being a game about hate and I think the
last part is very much a game about love
as much as it is about hey also like
well like love is asthma as much a a
motivating factor for the characters as
hate is and yeah like for me playing
through the game I remembered reading it
I remember being like I would like I
would like for this game not not to come
out right now because I just am not in
the mood I wish that somehow and this is
me speaking early-june right like I was
like me and I wish they would have
somehow switched around this game and
goes Tsushima because go Tsushima at the
time was a game where I was like man I'm
very much way more in the mood to play
that happy game and to play a game like
the last was part 2 and when I was
actually playing it the lastest part to
you I remember probably like quite a few
hours in being like man I am engrossed
and I am not having a problem with this
game the way I thought I was gonna have
a problem with this game like this game
is doing such an excellent job of
feeling like an escape like it's an
escape into a world rim and dark and and
messed up and all these different things
but it still worked and functioned as an
escape because the game is so engrossing
and in its story and in this world and
in his characters and so I'm with you
that like that is definitely at the top
of my list for games this year not my
number one necessarily it might become
the year ends but halfway through what
hopefully do what's in the running right
now and this could all change but right
now it's Final Fantasy 7 remake I love
that game and like I have because I'm a
huge nerd I have like a running document
a Google document like all my favorite
games of all time
UDT okay so I'm not gonna only one thank
God I do I will preface this that like
as of the day I finished last is part
two I put last is Part C literally one
space right below Final Fantasy 7 remake
right above last was coincidentally and
so like they're very close and asked me
next week it might change but five
phases that remake was a game for me
that that like I don't know man knocked
me out like I was not expecting to love
that game as much as I did because I did
not play the original final fancy 7
I have no affinity for Final Fantasy in
general like I kind of have this running
thing where I am not able to get into
Final Fantasy games you know I've tried
playing the original I tried playing
Final Fantasy 13 which I know is the
wrong one to try and play according to
many people and like I also tried
playing Final Fantasy 14 which is the
different thing but like I've tried
getting into Final Fantasies in the past
like even Kingdom Hearts you know which
which are games that I like I've never
really fallen in love with those types
of fantasy games fantasy JRPGs and Final
Fantasy 7 remake playing it I was like
man I I don't it's this combination of
the world because it is this fantasy
sci-fi meld cyberpunk
like it's melted this melted different
you know types of types of I guess
sci-fi fantasy that they present to you
it's that plus the characters that are
feel so real despite being so anime and
so like over-the-top
Barrett speech toward the beginning and
hitting even multiple speeches I that he
gives throughout the game as far as him
being like hey like you know Mach o is
the lifeblood of our world and him like
kind of going on the spiel of why
they're eco-terrorist and why they're
doing what they're doing like I like I
felt that and I found that not only in
the writing but in the performance and
in the face in the facial capture and I
mean a facial capture but in the
animation like I I felt that all their
story moments that happen like I I don't
really want to point out any the ones
I'm thinking of because it spoilers but
there are big story moments that happen
that for me I found really touching and
really
um at times heartbreaking and like I
know there's something about that game
that felt like magic as I was playing
through it like something about it felt
like almost almost feel like a a Disney
Pixar's like I can't believe y'all put
this pulled this off with such quality
and made me invest it in the story in a
way that this feels to me this laughing
isn't 7 remake made me feel the way I
felt playing the last list on ps3 and
2013 anyway where I was like this feels
like it's an iconic story that's gonna
like sit with me forever I you know
loved the battle system so I've only
played like I only really played Final
Fantasy 15 before Stephan and I think
the thing that stuck out most to me
would remake was just how confident it
was compared to 15 like 15 was like I
enjoyed that game for what it was but it
was it was it was kind of a mess like
there was like is it kind of interesting
open-world decisions and and like the
combat was kind of okay but it like it
worked but it wasn't I don't know it was
lacking that punch and like right from
the beginning of seven even though I
don't think I liked it as much as you
did like there's it's just it's so hard
to put down because of that confidence
in the way it just like puts you right
in it and you start going and the combat
feels so good and it looks so good and
the music is incredible music all that
comes together like it really it's it's
so hard to just I don't know like that's
all I was doing for like three or four
days I was just playing that game yeah
and the way I compare it cuz let the
found phases every make versus the
lastest conversation is so hard for me
because they're two completely different
game totally different things it's hard
to really compare them head-on but by
the time I finished final phases 7
remake and I was what 35 36 hours in I
did not want it to stop I wanted the
game to keep on going I like I finished
the game in to me at least started a new
game I wanted it to last forever whereas
with the last part to buy some I got
toward the end of the game I was like
I'm ready for this then and it kept
going and I was like please stop I can't
take this anymore please and like I'll
still love the last as part too
and I think like the the way in which it
kind of stretched serve the story even
though I felt like kind of did a
disservice to some of the gameplay
like overall like look I came out of
those two experiences feeling such a
love for Final Fantasy 7 remake and more
so like of a fascination and
appreciation for it last is part 2 yeah
I think for me like you've pretty much
hit the nail on the head there like lost
first to storytelling is so
sophisticated and like it's it's I think
it's it's one of the crowning
achievements of narrative within
videogames I said I feel like and I say
that as someone who I think in other
ways I don't think it's that all that
great I found the combat to be good for
a while but then very quickly became
grating and felt like a chore and I get
that there's narrative and almost like
thematic reasoning for some of that but
it's hard to get over the fact that
you're not having a good time to to you
know appreciate the oh it has it serves
a purpose and you know the monotony of
all this is kind of part of its feeling
but there's still the what it does with
its kind of characterization and the
themes the more it's one of those games
where the more you think about it the
more you can continue to find new things
about it like you talked about Druckman
saying it being a game about hate and
then you talked about saying oh for you
it's a game about love for me I took I
walked away with it thinking that this
is a game about forgiveness and and not
either of those two things and like
that's something I've been thinking
about for ages that I've been writing
and deleting and writing and doing again
over and over various kind of like takes
on on what it means and there's no other
game this year that has you know is
living in my mind rent-free in the way
that it is like it's it's I think about
what I'm like sitting down in a moment I
open my notes up and write some thoughts
about it and send it to some friends and
see what they think about it and that
kind of stuff having said that one of us
is a game that like you said when I
finished playing I felt good I felt like
I had a I felt uplifted even though the
way it ends is not specifically that's
not what they want you feel is an
element of it but it just felt like a
good life-affirming
or gamer affirming experience if you
know I'm saying like you walk away from
that being like you're walking from loss
was being like this is the power of
video games you walk away from final
fantasy thinking this is why I play
video games this is why I enjoy video
games this is what I want video games to
make me feel if every game can make me
feel like this game it would be
incredible and like I get the same
feeling as that I give that same feeling
from personify royal which came out this
year yeah and it's that I think those
three games are currently leading the
pack for me as my favorite games of the
year I'm not ready to entertain and
entertain a game of the year discussion
because there still loads of games
coming out and I feel like game of the
year discussions frame the the the
actual discussion itself in a different
way like you know what's your favorite
game versus what's the most impactful
what's most important etc etc I'm just I
do not have the energy to start on
picking those elements of it but I think
loss of us is a profound experience and
easily one of the best games of the year
so far it's the same for Final Fantasy
and same for personify of royalty suffer
they do in persona 5 is just fantastic
like the way obviously we're on record
as being the very persona friendly
podcast we all have people I love it on
us on our team and then you know
blessings here and blessings noted for a
personified fan persona for persona like
this is a crew of noted persona like us
so like personify this already
especially came to many of us but the
fact that they did what they did to that
game to make it even better it's kind of
like standing it's unreal how good that
game is like we see we would have we
gave it a pretty high score and speak of
you simply about it but if you have told
me like a few years ago they're gonna
make this game even better I would not
have believed it
well that's the thing you do this that's
the thing for me we're persona 5
original I played in 2017 and for me as
somebody who played persona 4 golden and
like I think 2015
16 for the first time it absolutely fell
in love with it so much so they became
one of my favorite games of all time I
played persona 5 and I had so many
complaints with it I liked and part of
it was just the fact that like persona 4
golden be my first persona I just loved
the characters more I love the story
persona 4 more like I like the
soundtrack persona 4 more and I know
that's like I'm probably a controversial
thing to say but persona 4 just did it
for me and all they're all in all these
different ways and persona 5 like I had
complaints with like yeah oh man the
characters don't seem like deeper
interesting enough I don't know man like
the dungeons are cool visually but I
have some problems with some of the
dungeon design and some of the combat
and like I don't know how I feel about
the balancing of the battle system and
all this stuff all the stuff I had
complaints with jumping into persona 5
royal some I don't know how but somehow
it fixed everything in a way where now
I'm like oh yeah persona 5 roles know
Mike one of my favorite games of all
time - like it's it's it's crazy right
like with just the small things they've
added as far as features into the
dungeons and the battle system that
stuff builds in a way that now makes it
flow so well for me like that thing SP
has done oh my god so much yeah like
it's so huge
oh yeah that combat was already pre
slick now it just absolutely sings like
this lines there's times where I'll do a
standard enemy encounter and didn't just
save the encounter because of how
slickly it went like just a baton pass
they're exploiting weakness the rush or
that kind of stuff it's just like it's
the most I think it's probably my
favorite RPG turn-based RPG mechanic
system of all time like it feels so good
and there's there's others as well that
are amazing you know the Final Fantasy
vagrant story that kind of stuff but
this one is just like top to bottom it's
just buttery smooth and so cool to watch
incredible game and like yet the new
content they've added as well as a
quality of life stuff that all being
amazing but the new content they added
is like considered really well thought
out and addresses things that were
missing from the previous game like the
mental-health angle is a big part of
that right like that was something that
people
came away and and well like it doesn't
really explore the impact of that and
how they deal with that at all and then
they went away and did that which is
unexpected because you don't get a lot
of these types of games doing exploring
in the angle of I mean mental health is
a big part of the persona and Shin
Megami Tensei series as a whole but I
didn't expect them to go back in
retrofit with this much amount of
content and address that kind of stuff
and speak to it it's just so well done
and then there's a new character and all
of that kind of business it's just like
an amazing package for anyone who plays
RPGs
I went from someone who was not gonna
play persona 5 royal because like I
don't know if I've got the time dedicate
and then a couple weeks ago I bought it
on PlayStation I bought it on the
PlayStation Store so I think eventually
I'm gonna end up replaying that
hopefully this year just because like I
don't know what I was expecting like I
figured like I knew there'd be a new
character and either be some more story
stuff but I didn't think I would get the
urge to play a hundred and fifty hour
RPG I mean here 110 hour RPG I guess I
think took me like 110 hours but like
hearing everyone talk about it and stuff
like that it sounds like it makes some
significant meaningful additions that
make me a excited to jump back into some
of them are like the interesting thing
is by some of them like it took me a
while to realize they were actually
there because yeah some of them are
likes just like tweaks that improve the
experience so much that it's almost like
they work because you can't tell
anything is yeah more than a new feature
and so like I've streamlined days to
like just be like normally you wouldn't
do anything it's just like alright we're
just gonna jump to the next day yeah
yeah that's the thing you can go out at
night and now they've made it so that
within your home you can basically do do
a thing that'll add to your overall like
social stats and so like if you want you
can raise your your confidence level or
your whatever level by like doing
something that and you're in your own
home which was missing from the first
game and which like makes me feel like
you're not wasting time and also you can
press the the touchpad and that'll then
make it so that you it'll it'll then
have like automatic suggestions for
things you can do
you know like essentially teleport you
to those things to which will which
streams like streamlines it a great
amount that's that's one of those games
where you you enter the flow state or
the wave you want to call it almost like
a slipstream of gaming where if you want
to tune the world out and just get
absorbed in the game the rhythm of
persona 5 and personify burrell more
specifically it's just so like the
momentum except and then pulls you
forward with is so good that you just
forget the world exists around you like
more so than any other game you're just
so engrossed in it but yeah I think
those three games loss of us from a
Fantasy 7 remake and personify while
leading the pack but I do have a list of
games in front of me if you want me to
shower Mountain sure yeah once I'm out
this year that we forgot about so
there's a game that I do when I give a
shout out to which I've played a ton of
in a game that I thought I was done with
but I've been playing it again is animal
crossing new horizons oh my god that was
this year that was this year oh yeah
that is a game that I have spent I think
like 250 hours it's Shane Callie's not
on today because she would she would be
the one championing this game for sure
but that's a game that I do and give a
shout out to because like a it was such
a phenomenon it still is like the amount
of people who were so invested in this
game was absurd like I'm I know Nintendo
I'm sure Nintendo knew who was gonna be
a success but like probably not to this
extent I don't know how they could have
predicted like you know Gary Whitta
stalk show which ended up being huge and
getting all these celebrities on it
saying sting was on it yeah Danny Trejo
was on it like all these girls that
recurring character on it yeah Aaron
guest which is which is insane but like
even beyond that too like so many people
have gotten a switch just for this game
and he's connected with so many people
who normally wouldn't play games would
be interested in and like but it's also
connected to someone like me who I've
been a fan of all the Animal Crossing
games I've played them all at least all
the mainline ones but like this one it
just seems to work so well with how
they're implementing updates with
seasons like it seems like a big thing
that was missing from Animal Crossing
and all the previous games like is now
there because of this whole like
they called lifestyle games or they
update as they go or live service games
and I feel like just the animal crossing
formula has been perfected I mean if
there even was an animal crossing
formula and that's a game that you know
like I said I thought I was done with
but I am still playing every single day
even if it's just for a couple minutes
and like it always I don't know like
tomorrow was saying how Final Fantasy
made him feel really good and like it
was a game that made you feel great and
I feel the same way about Animal
Crossing and that like even if I play
like 20 minutes or so usually I'm
walking away in a good mood because I
don't know I chatted with one of my
villagers or I caught a fish that I've
been trying to catch for a while and the
writing is super clever and fun I like I
got so many good things to say about
that game glad to hear it let me tell
you about a game called predator hunting
grounds which I know you guys are too
cowardly to shout it out I played that
many times I've also fought through
motion sickness to play that with Greg
in you guys I don't know the framerate
is working and like there's a way day
moves like this there is a slight
disconnect between what you're doing and
on the controller and the way just make
sure yeah yeah there is yeah there is
when you press that aim button okay just
slide and that kind of stuff is just
like oh so just so he's so Jenny but I
love it
it's so janky like I really enjoyed I
will say Irene joined it when we played
the beta and a lot of fun with it and it
was really janky but then I played it
when it came out and it was just like it
was the motion sickness it did it for me
like I just I physically can't play it
which sucks and I don't know what change
between beater and final release and
maybe they fixed it out but I had such a
fun time that take that like just after
launch I mean y'all played together that
I had to lie down for the whole
afternoon and just like not look at
stuff they say haven't fixed her and on
the day that it came out I got it and
installed it and I got a bug the bug was
you know on this main screen where shows
you your predator
there yeah none of that none of that was
textured for me so it was just a bunch
of triangles that look vaguely like the
predator so it looks awful and it
doesn't have any hands it doesn't have a
head it's just like parts of its body
floating there I want to only it's one
of your favorite games though blessing I
don't ya [ __ ] on it
to this day if I load the game up it is
still like that that's a home that is
permanently my version of predator now
on the screen and like I'm just like
good and that's like I enjoy playing
that game with you guys specifically and
especially with like you know when
you're on and Greg's on and Andy's on
and and like folks are jumping in Nick's
on that's fun that's fun to play and it
makes it worth feeling sick to play it
but a farewell I will never of my own
volition go and fire up some pretty so
and that's actually where I'm where I'm
at with it to you like I don't think
it's one of the best games of 2020 by
any stretch but it is a game that came
out in 2020
that I will say that is if I was making
a list that was top 10 games 2020 that
I've had the most fun with I could see
it possibly making that list like it is
it is a good time especially with
friends to play with but ya know I just
want to give it a shout-out as I came
out 2020 if it's ok with you Jake
podcast master house master oh sure are
some games that I've gotten a list yeah
people can so we've done a feature I
think it should be up fairly soon or is
up which is basically the best games of
state 2020 so far and that's part of
that we kind of caught a bunch of games
into a spreadsheet so I'm gonna read
them out only do one more quickly
don't turn all doom eternal is on my I
was the first one I was gonna say I
figured that would be on there and I
want to make sure we get to it before I
use how do you guys feel about the
conversation around do eternal because I
feel like that's a game that everybody
expected to come out and blow us all
away and then they came out and I think
it blew us all away but nobody's really
talking about it since I bounced off
that game to it like it felt like he was
trying to do too much I will I went in
there maybe it's my own fault for
expecting more of the same but I won I
won a day like a slick focus
fast-paced shoot that I could play and
like almost barrel through and get just
get like the satisfaction out of and
it's doing the thing where just like go
to the ship and go back and these open
issue environments that you have to
platformer and I was like I'm not here
for that I just want I just want the the
ish shredding metal music and jumping
around firing rockets and shooting guns
and it felt like it overcomplicated
itself like it had a good thing going
and there's like huh try to be too smart
I was like and then you add disability
and not billions like I don't need that
so it came out the same days Animal
Crossing which yeah you know completely
dominated the conversation yeah also
also another game that's got like motion
sickness fights to it well no they fixed
they fixed it for eternal the they
actually put especially in the console
version they've added a bunch more
accessibility options and you can
because I couldn't do doom 2016 but
eternal I could play yes I I never mess
with the console accessible easy it's
this game I want to go back to cuz I did
enjoy playing it also it's a amazing
case use case for the Xbox elite
controller because oh yeah you just
press all the things and you're doing
all the fans on the screen so like I I
want to use it more for that um but yeah
it kind of like came and went really
quickly like if I had if I had one
complaint with doom eternal it would
have been the fact that I thought the
game moves faster than like both I can
handle in both like the design of the
game could handle because at a certain
point especially toward the end of the
game I feel like there's so many enemies
I did through through in there with you
and especially the Marauder I think it
was the guy that like like the Marauders
yeah that dude was doing way too much
but yeah they would like throw Marauders
at you they throw like a bunch of
different people while the Marauders
there and like at a certain point I was
like man this is going way too fast like
I cannot keep up there are too many
enemies on screen there's too much
happening that said I had an absolute
blast with it like you know I do 2016 is
one my favorite if not my favorite
first-person shooter of this generation
and like I mean that's for I think
obvious reasons right like it came out
and it read it read
it was super smooth super focused and
straightforward in terms of what it came
out to be and do doom-doom eternal felt
like it saw June 2016 it was like
alright let's do that let's do that
bless up the ante and the ways in which
it up the ante might have they might
have they might have upped it too much
yeah that's why I'm like man I cuz I
love to eternal but if they're gonna
make another doom I would like them to
be like alright let's let's turn it down
a little bit let's take a step back
let's uh let's go back let's relax and
maybe like get more linear I don't know
I think I'm with you there because as
much as I did like that game and it'll I
mean I imagine if it is on my top 10 it
might be on the lower end of it but like
that is a game that it I feel like it
demands a lot of you which isn't a bad
thing like that's probably one of my
favorite things about it but like I
couldn't just binge that game like I
couldn't just sit down and play through
it I'd have to take breaks and the
problem with that was that like as you
get further the more it throws at you
then it's like trying to remember how
you deal with every enemy type mostly
the Marauder because the Marauder your
strategy is completely different and
like I don't know I imagine I'd be
curious to hear your experiences like
tomorrow going back to it after not
playing it for a while because actually
that might be not fun my plan is to once
I get my new PC play on that oh yeah
because I'm Way more comfortable with
mouse and keyboard with shooters and
also specifically that game is like the
the flick of the wrist that you need to
to move around and you know react to
what's happening around you is so
demanding and I just can't get it on a
controller there there is a flow state
that you can enter playing that game
absolutely it it is that type of game
where once you get into it like yeah for
me I felt like I was entering a new
dimension which i think is the magical
thing about doom eternal is that it kind
of transports you into that world and
you feel like you're like you are what's
his name
doom guy to Slayer like you feel like
you are him you are embodying him and
you're [ __ ] going a million miles per
hour yes when it does that it is a blast
and like I'm like
that's honestly my but I don't really
have like any heavy complaints with the
game like I think the game is overall
fantastic but like it's not that much
more fantastic than doing 2016 is and I
think that's kind of where as far as
like the best games of 2020 go that's
kind of where the conversation kind of
ends with it's like yes another one of
those have you this is a bit of a
tangent but have you guys watched any
clips of when Joe Rogan interviews
Hugo Martin no no in full it is
absolutely painful once cuz he got him
on the show for some reason like I was
curious because I was like why is Hugo
Martin on Joe Rogan so I like click
didn't watch little bit of it but it is
absolutely painful I'm sure I'll get
hate from people who listen to this
because people love Joe Rogan but like
it is so hard to watch most of the
interview is is Joe Rogan being like but
wise why isn't there like multiplayer
why can't we like 1v1 each other and he
goes like ah you know we just didn't
make that kind of game and he's like but
man that's like the best part of games
when I can when we can do one-on-ones
and he's like why is he on your Rogan I
don't know just think it was so
confusing like I just I saw it and I was
like oh my god that's funny I want to
see Joe Rogan actually nevermind I was
gonna I was gonna say I want to see Joe
Rogan interviewed Jonathan Blow but I
actually don't another game that cameras
here Streets of Rage for you played that
I want to it's good game fun I'm shadow
hunt down is what it's called I think
yeah I think it's called hunt down
similar kind of game like side-scrolling
shoot-'em-up kind of a boss rush ish
game because while you're doing mostly
my game is about his boss battles really
really fun game it's probably one of my
favorite indie games I've played so far
this year Nora are you ready to feel
really feel the passage of time yes yeah
dreams came out this year yeah and I
would put that up there for me at least
I really like dreams yes good game
obviously called qualitative warzone a
bunch of games are like perhaps not as
got cornering as much attention as like
The Last of Us but like pokemon mystery
dungeon rescue team das came out Evans
remains came out if found Shantae and
the seven sirens xenoblade chronicles
definitive edition oh yeah over to our
resident weep jake deca that game was
good that game was really good I gave it
a 9 I liked it a lot I it's hard for me
to like think about the games that came
out like that that's what a 2007 game
that got remastered so when I'm thinking
of my favorite games of 2020 that
probably won't be on the list but it is
you know a superb game yep
resident evil 3 remake came out this
figure yeah yeah yeah absolutely III
disappointed I was I didn't play it cuz
I liked wasn't they were free law and I
was like just I'm good I'm all right you
know and like in a vacuum it's a really
good game but coming off as an evil 2
players I go through such a bummer to me
yeah already and the will of the wisps
it's really good also it felt like a
chore every moment I played it I think I
just I I wasn't I don't know if I just
wasn't in the mindset for it but the
things that I usually love about
Metroidvania sweer just really annoying
me I can't reach a dead end and be like
oh that's my thing is like why haven't
Metroidvania is evolved like that's my
main Belle's kind of my main critique
with Orion the little twist like you get
to dead ends and I feel like at a
certain point somebody should have
thought of the idea to let us draw on
the map and let us like or it was icons
like they have in breath the wild where
you can ya and find an x icon and place
that on the map so you know that you
like you personally know that you're not
supposed to go there like this it's a
really interesting line of game
yeah who's making for it yeah it's an
interesting line of thought because like
the the the evolution of the
metroidvania genre seems to have come at
the expense of it because instead of
evolving that genre people have just
taken the core of it and made new genres
which is like wild because like you know
it's just endless like a roguelike or
whatever it may be
so like that that genre has just kind of
fallen by the wayside the core of it and
instead of trying to evolve it people it
very quickly went from being this new
exciting Chandra to being a genre that
you now pay homage to almost like too
quickly like instead of doing the next
evolutionary step we've got Igarashi
doing I'm making a symphony of the night
like game which is like white first of
the moon to is about to come out I think
yeah like don't make that same game
again make the next phase in that game
and maybe it's maybe we're asking for
too much by trying to come up with new
ways I feel like you can do stuff like
that which is quality of life stuff but
you know instead of just moving on to
another genre but who knows maybe that
is the evolution and we're we're like
not given credit and at a certain point
and like this good sound controversial
but I don't mean in a controversial way
I feel like you know once you play one
Metroidvania you kind of played them all
in a sense that like or in the world all
the wisp individually is like a very
excellent game and like us it's also
very touching game like it's it's a very
beautiful game that do such great things
with it but like in terms of the the
rounds I'm going through in my head as
I'm playing the game I'm like okay cool
yeah now I find the new ability now I'm
able to go to this place haven't been to
before okay cool I go there oh sweet I
can explore a bit alright dead ends
sweet new ability found it now I can go
through the dead ends and it's it's that
same kind of gameplay loop in a way
where like yeah bit we've seen
Metroidvania is kind of adapted and
turned into something like adapted in
either like turn into another genre or I
guess adapted in ways where you get
games like Batman Arkham Asylum which is
pretty much for all intensive purposes
at metroidvania but it is doing it in a
way that works for I guess this
third-person action design we see metro
beings kind of grow and evolve in that
way to wait to where now like me playing
an actual Metroidvania that is like hey
we're we're making a super super metroid
or we're making a Castlevania something
symphony of the night just feels way
less exciting to me mmm yeah I think a
couple weeks ago someone had asked us a
question like what are some tropes in
indie games that you're tired of and
mine was not sure
Vania because I like like you were
saying like I feel like once you've
played a handful of Metroidvania games
like you kind of hit those same notes
every single time that said though like
that word always gets me excited when
like there's a game it's likely it's
gonna have Metroidvania elements I'm
like ooh was that me like that cool yeah
that's me and Roble
like if you say ro glad I'm like oh yeah
that too yeah let's go but like rogue
lights are kind of kind of have the same
thing where a lot of them are doing or
do have the same kind of gameplay little
but they're still satisfying though so
I'm okay with it I'm gonna rattle off
some names just to get through them
because I know we've been running for a
bit now and we want to wrap it up so
they get mentions yeah so other games
that came out that are not worthy
valoran under night in barfi actually
lazy oh I'll just call it that it's
probably wrong yeah treachery and
beatdown City Tokyo Mirage sessions Fe
encore wonderful 101 remastered
spongebob battle for bikini bottom
murder by numbers minecraft dungeons MLB
the show
kunai Kentucky route zero act 5 genital
savage planet conjunct late and grand
blue Fantasy Versus which I reviewed and
thought it was good um call for Mars
gears tactics Dragon Ball Z Kakarot
Desperados 3 I think oh wow how long is
this year come on Rocky Mount I think
that I think that come on bleeding edge
neo - oh yeah edge came out and died
this year did you get split I played it
out to die by Microsoft
that's a bummer man cuz I loved engine
theory yeah I mean they were bought for
hell-blade right they was a bleeding
edge Neo tooth and of course the biggest
game the clubhouse games Oh actually I
was gonna bring up clubhouse games and
like my what have I been playing segment
I like that game though that game should
have done a lot more and it's for bond
for person online is very it's very much
a bummer that like only like five games
are playable for four people online and
I came yeah
yeah those those are kind of like the
main the big standouts from the USO for
that we've kind of identified so yeah
two out of ten this is a list of games
that are not worthy that came out not
games of the year one game I don't think
we reviewed that I am excited to try out
that a lot of people were saying is one
of their favorites is sledge life oh did
that come out it's it's on epic story
now it's free on Epic Games story I
think but it's supposed to come to
switch to it said it was out on switch I
could not find it on the switch story
the other day okay I think maybe it's
not the game where they that was one
game where they announced the switch
version and developers like hmm oh that
was indivisible yeah yeah I was the
other day because everyone was saying
how good it is and I was like I want to
check that game out but I don't want to
play it on I want to play it on my
switch and it's not there this is this
is specifically a reference just for
Lucy and any other British person but
every time someone says large life I
hear a sparkle I feel my hair yeah
shout out to jump rope challenge on
switch oh yeah what game this is gonna
sound like a joke but I'm being totally
serious one of my favorite games in this
year so far has been Star Wars Episode
one racer that came that re-released
this last week it was two weeks ago on
ps4 yeah I heard that it's a great game
unless you're really bad at it and can't
get a platinum yeah no exactly okay I
was like that's new sounds really
familiar yeah it was gonna say he's he
sees away five times in a row he's done
well yeah I try to get the Platinum and
episode 1 racer and the Platinum was
broken for me I think because I use
cheats Jordan beginning my play cheated
she is don't I I was confused because
some of the trophies seemed like they
wanted me to cheat to get it
it was like a trophy that was like win a
race in mirror mode and the way look I
looked it up online in the way to unlock
mirror mode was to put in sheets but
apparently also if I beat attract I
didn't lock me remote I don't know that
they're somebody some of the cheats
worked to get me trophies is what I'm
saying and the fact that like some of
the cheats might have locked me off from
other trophies how's that there
insistency again ridiculous yeah but I
had a blast that game and also burnout
paradise force which oh yeah I've been
wanting to play that again anyway I know
these are old games but listener
questions yes all right before we get
into the listener questions if you want
us to read your question on the show you
can email us at after dark podcast at
gamespot.com or you can join a discord
by DMing anyone well not don't the end
blessing he won't be able to get you
into the game spot this court but
tomorrow Lucy and myself can get you
right into the game spot discord and
there's a channel right there where you
can sound off questions or you just chat
with other listeners and whatnot it's a
very good community but the first
question here comes from loose and light
Lucy doing read this first one hello
yeah uh from new tonight has the pin
games that you didn't play for a long
time because if you're feeling of
anticipation was greater than actually
playing the game so me when breath of
the wild came out I was so excited to
play and enjoy the game that it took me
a while to actually play because that
anticipation made me happy and I didn't
mind waiting even though nothing was
stopping me I did this with Skyrim i
mean i guess i played skyrim when i
first got it i me too i just played a
little bit of it and i knew it was gonna
be something i was like i was waiting
for it for years super excited for it
and like i think that call of duty
modern warfare 2 came out around the
same time or maybe it was like black ops
or something i don't i don't i bought it
within the with Assassin's Creed
Revelations and I stupidly played
Assassin's Creed Revelations first dana
played skyrim
even though i had both of them and i
could have done but same time i I think
I did sir no maybe was left 4 dead 2
I don't know there was a lot of games
that came out that year yeah but I
remember that being a game that I played
about 20 minutes of and I like stopped
not because I wasn't in
because I was enjoying how excited I was
to play it I guess
yeah plus there was a bunch of other
great games that were out so I just set
it aside and then you know a month or
two later came back to it and sunk a lot
of time and do it but I think even when
I was done with it I was like yeah I
didn't like that as much as oblivion and
I'm just kind of yeah I had that with
XCOM chimera squadron recently I was so
excited to play it and then I bought it
and the moment I bought it just every
bit of excitement disappeared like I was
just like done I was more excited for
the prospect of having XCOM than
actually playing it I'm sure I'll get to
it eventually but I was just like okay I
got this right yeah runs like absolute
trash and everything for some reason
though blessing I feel like death
stranding might be one for me where like
that game I was I was super excited for
like I don't think I had been as excited
for many other games as I was for death
stranding just because I'm a big Cody
more person and the idea of him working
on a new IP just like seemed very
exciting to me but that game came out
around the same time as pokemon sword
and shield and then also Jedi fall in
order and like by the time those games
were coming out I was like all right I
might prioritize that's training less
because like I'm already excited for it
I could I'm fine with like you know
maintaining this this excitement
especially like after reading reviews
and saying that like so many people were
like schemes actually kind of boring I
was kind of fine putting it off for that
and then yeah by some I actually got to
it like I was still like I was still
kind of really excited for the game and
I'll still somewhat a family play even
like with a fan of it even without
necessarily having played it I just like
the idea in like the what I had seen a
game playing and and the thought of it I
played some of it and at a certain point
I kind of like fell off just because
other things happen and I've not gone
back since like and that's not that's
it's still a game where I'm like yeah
had a like this is I consider a
fantastic I consider it really cool I
like a lot I like a lot of what the game
was doing but at the same time I've just
not had it in me to kind of go back
to it and I guess that's that that's
kind of where where that answers that
for me I think I'm going through that
now with the PC version where I'm so
happy with the PC version and I'm
worried that when it comes out it's
gonna be like yeah I am the biggest
surprise of 2020 for me is how excited I
am to play des training again on PC
because I didn't even like the game like
I thought it was great but it just
didn't I was frustrated most of the time
playing that game even though overall I
did like it but for some reason I think
it's just like seeing that game run on
PC I'm like I'm like yeah I'm ready for
this I'm ready to go back and do and do
it in widescreen and max out the
graphics and whatnot and just you know
these are on and read us for gonna use
mods like the moment he's got like
infinite sprint make him like the Road
Runner next question from depressed
carbon do you wanna take this one
tomorrow so has there been a game that
even though it's old you went back and
played mostly speaking about consoles
although playing half-life the pinna
game that even though it's old you went
back and played I think - I think it I
think they're talking about like Bri
plugging in an old console Oh after the
fact I think man would have to be
Ocarina of Time which was not of my
generation although is not that old it's
still graphically outdated I find it to
be still visually appealing freezing and
the music is some of my favorite video
game music next to undertale I hope you
guys are doing well and stay safe so
basically going back after the fact
damn plays good opinions yeah yeah by
the way yeah
depressed carbon you've got good
opinions blessing improved abrió super
smash bros melee was one for me that I I
guess I haven't played recently but
that's a game that I always go back to
because it did not like brawl at all and
I got rid of my weak but I never got rid
of my Gamecube I'd always hook up my
gamecube well I've gotten rid of my
Gamecube since then but like I kept that
for so much longer and I'd always plug
that back in just to play Super Smash
Bros
anyway um for me it's difficult because
all of my old consoles that up at my
mum's and I kind of left him there when
I moved so I haven't really gone back
and played anything old in a long time
yeah that's why I answer sadly ain't
dishonor it's not bowed that's the same
console generation right because I'm
playing definitive edition oh well I
guess I did play Mass Effect one again
last summer but I played on PC this time
technically I did sidon I said starting
on Xbox I played and then but then I
changed it to PC I think that counts
though I do regular playthroughs of
Metal Gear Solid and yeah at this point
I'm doing on the video because it's just
oh how was it playing I playing through
like 2 and 3 or 1 otherwise I'm playing
through one at the moment hmmmm at the
moment I'm playing through one yeah are
you played 2 in 3 on the Vita I have
played to enthrone the Vita it's and it
requires a little finger gymnastics to
get it done properly for stuff like you
know when you aim first-person and then
look and then like get on your tippy
toes
yeah like shoot and that kind of stuff
it involves like the touchpad as well to
get the the menu system up and you can
fiddle with it but it doesn't feel
elegant but it feels playable sadly they
are taking it out of game paths fairly
soon I believe so I really yeah
otherwise that would be the way I would
recommend played two and three in the HD
collection but yeah the tsa's doesn't
game that I would go back to a lot and I
always regularly play the beginning of
Super Metroid just like there just until
the point where it starts to open up
like the opening sequence and then do a
bit of like a few the early areas is
because it feels good to play that game
yeah those are the probably the two I
play most frequently and I love going
back and revisiting old game especially
ones that have in place like Star Wars
Episode one racer for the most part was
a game that I hadn't played much of as a
kid I played at a friend's house but
that was only like the first few tracks
of it and so like actually going through
and playing through all the tracks was a
really fun time for me
I played banjo kazooie all the way
through for the first time in 2016
toward the end of 2016 and it became
like
my favorite platformers I think what
else
Ocarina of Time was a game I play for
the first time in like 2013 and really
really enjoyed it yeah like I tend to
regularly go back to two games just cuz
I don't know there's something about
older games that I feel like are fun at
least for me as somebody who was in ssb4
kid and like spent so much time with
that and the ps2 growing up I feel like
for me I going back to those consoles
one is kind of nostalgic but then also I
feel like they translate well for me in
terms of games not aging up well or
whatever I'm able to play a ps2 game
kind of almost in the same mindset as I
would have played it in in like 2003 or
whatever one yes she was so relevant
alright following up on the press
carbons question is there an old game
that you enjoyed but can't go back to it
due to its graphics controls etc being
older janky that one's from Robert Jay
first one that comes to mind for me are
like Knights of the Old Republic as much
as I loved those games I feel like I've
tried to play them again a couple times
and it just didn't it didn't hit like it
did back in 2004 whenever it came out
last of us men oh really I tried to play
I tried to play that at the end of last
year and it just feels so different like
it feels like a very 2013 game and it
just doesn't feel smooth to play at all
and that was back before Naughty Dog had
really figured out shooting like I have
always said and I've always believed
that the shooting in the Uncharted games
has never felt satisfying up until for
and lost legacy and yet I think last of
us are still very much in that ballpark
and it just feels I don't know it just
feels very very different but I love I
love the story so much that like when
they lead up to - I decided to just
watch a let's play through instead of
playing again it's not even like that it
feels bad
or that it looks bad it still looks
great it's just it just felt different
to me I just I just felt like I didn't
really want to go back and play it's
just like just awkward enough to make in
not not enjoyable not not enjoyable but
like it just doesn't feel comfortable
like it feels weird yeah yeah I kind of
think of one but I can't think of
anything that like just to throw it out
there I've been I've been watching
whenever listeners fogey bear by
watching his stream and he was streaming
Walking Dead Season 1 ohm and that is
the game I could never return to as much
as I liked it wouldn't came out watching
him play was just like oh boy this game
is a aged a lot like the writing is
still great the writing is still really
good but like I don't know I walk I you
know when they're at the hotel and he's
like walking around trying to get chalk
and he's just like blindly walking on
he's like I've talked to everyone I
don't know what I'm missing and then you
find a piece of chalk and it triggers
the next scene and it's like in what
world does finding a piece of chalk like
trigger I don't know it's so strange it
made sense at the time but watching it I
was like yeah there's no way I can I
miss telltale man I do too
I mean Walking Dead Season 2's happening
somehow you're lucky and I really liked
Walking Dead - to be fair like I don't
like I thought that game was fantastic
at the time and in some regard I still
do but man watching someone play figure
that again I was like no I don't think I
could do it hmm there's like platformers
from the night easier or that I would
love to be able to play again but I just
can't because they feel bad like even
like the Spyro games I mean they've been
remastered since and they feel a bit
better but I like the crashes as Pyro's
and its various other like platformers
from back in that generation that I'm
like oh good try that but probably he's
not
I'd rather preserve my memory of it then
actually replay and potentially tarnish
that I mean I mean it's it's
I'm not I didn't necessarily love back
in the days I didn't play much way back
in the day but like every time I try to
play Resident Evil 4 for some reason I'm
not able to get into it which if I like
my most controversial video game you
were coming in here with the
controversial yeah
where's my res evil vortex who got me in
hot water in the past but for some
reason that games never been able to do
it for me and I and I mainly blame the
fact that I don't think the controls
aged well like I mean I haven't liked
that game did so much but it does feel
very very awkward to go back to I
finished that beam that game once and
I've started it probably 16 times like
nah I really like it it's really good
like at the front of my favorite games
but like for some reason I just it's
difficult to get through that because I
think it's because the opening of that
game I think is like incredible I mean
when it starts to get to the castle
areas when I kind of start to lose lose
interest on the inflaters the furthest
I've got in that game is playing it on
the Wii because I present yeah like it
surprisingly like I think it controls
pretty well but I got to a point where I
was like I am tired and holding my hands
up like like constantly I like legit I
physically got tired of it and I was
like I'm not playing this game anymore
I'm not gonna keep doing this but those
the closest I got to acted like playing
through that game anyway any last-minute
last-minute games the shut up before you
wrap this thing up no all right well
that's been episode 49 of GameSpot after
dark thank you all so much for listening
Thank You Lucy and two more for joining
and thank you blessing for guesting on
this episode I know it was pretty last
minute I really appreciate it yeah
thanks for having me this is the awesome
panel to me back if I'd be like
preferably on Michael Hyatt we'll have
Michael text me actually something to
say to you guys yeah no I had a text
back and be like can I say this on the
episode but you he he told me I can say
it and so if this is inappropriate
Michaels in trouble not me he sold me
that if I see Jake in Tam tell them to
his ass from the front okay yeah okay
that work that wouldn't be the first
time okay science told me to
SMD FB and he his ass from the front
tomorrow where can people find you on
twitter you can find me you find me on
Twitter at tomorrow hey I'm working on
what the hell am i working on things oh
yeah we've got audio look oh yeah we've
got audio logs - [ __ ] we're doing the
charity stream charity streams are
winding down this so be done Shelby what
the Friday one is a kind of awesome Dark
Alliance
that's chillin anyway chill stream where
it's gonna be a few of us just chatting
and talking about the playful experience
while we're talking about that we just
launched our game sports tour merge Thor
specifically for currently for play for
us if you go to stores or Gamescom
you'll find a bunch of really cool
merchandise there that you can buy
there's a t-shirt which is really cool
it's just like really low-key play for
logo is a hoodie there there's a
facemask there's a skateboard deck
there's a touched all that you can press
things without actually using your
fingers and a poster that's really cool
all proceeds from that until the from
June to the end of August 2020 go
directly 50-50 split between Direct
Relief and black lives matter so any
money that you spend there's going for a
good quote going to good causes and you
also get something called we've got the
t-shirts and the poster I've seen we've
got ourselves and they are super high
quality that's worth checking out I
actually really like the t-shirt so now
while it is stuff on there cuz it's like
kind of minimalist it's not yeah it
doesn't hit you with like crazy colors
and logos it's just very very subdued
which like Lucy how about you I'm on
Twitter at least see James games and
I've got a week off so peace out lads
I'll see you in a week you know actually
I keep forgetting I've also go week off
are you gonna miss episode 52 I mean
it's not like it would go in anywhere
I'm
yeah I mean will Doyle in Texas man I've
like I've done my taxes this week next
week I have to stop my student finance
I'm organizing my closet I'm cleaning my
bathroom like I've got big plans take a
crack at half life Alex maybe um but
there's nothing that would drop I've
lined up Diablo I'm ready to play some
Diablo
cannot wait I can't tell anything
serious or need to buy it cheap I missed
the sale since Greg was talking about
the other day which leads me to believe
he has it I mean baby blessing how are
you working we will find you what are
you working on you can find me on
twitter at blessing jr that's at
blessing j.r and if you can find my
content in youtube.com slash kind of
funny games over there i am a part of
kind of funny games daily which is our
daily news show that happens pretty much
every single day of the week weekday so
Monday through Friday and that happens
at 10 a.m. Pacific time on twitch.tv
sighs kind of funny games live so if you
like video game news tune into that if
you like PlayStation I host the play
student podcast with Greg Miller lucid
roommate Hertz teasing earlier and that
also is on youtube.com slash kind of
funny games PS I love you xoxo that's
also in your podcast services choice
where we love losing the podcast so
PlayStation video game news and other
shenanigans all happening kind of funny
question cat Diablo Diablo no I don't do
that look how it very much seems like
not my GM of again your coward is that
that Final Fantasy 14 update live that
suppose now yeah I got the man dang
listen if I couldn't get into x-men
legends I don't know if I'm getting them
dude Dave's not the same thing actually
actually did kind of get into excellent
legends does a lie you can find me at
Jacob deck and I don't know I'm working
on the podcast this podcast and oh I
know
jean-luc and I are doing we're gonna try
to make a cyberpunk video every single
week until the game comes out
I don't know we'll hit every week but
we're gonna try to be making styrofoam
videos very often the first one which
the script is already written is a
history of night city so a lot of these
are gonna be lower based so if you're
someone who's super excited for
cyberpunk 2077 and you know nothing
about the world that these videos are
for you even if you know a good amount
like we're gonna try to touch on
everything from mystery of night city to
the different gangs to the different
districts to the different characters so
if that's something you're interested in
be sure to stay tuned for that I'm very
excited for those videos I think they're
gonna be a lot of fun old strategy : and
see if it pays off for them yep all
right
see y'all next week
[Music]